úgy lebegett a levegőbe hogy aki a
pszichológushoz megy annak valami baja
van az beteg az és és az egyik
osztálytársam el kellett menjen
pszichológushoz és mindenki úgy úgy
rejtetten nem tudtunk róla beszélni nem
szavak nélkül is úgy az atmoszférában
benne volt az hogy biztos azért meg
gyogyó
és valahogy úgy teltek az évek nem
nagyon gondolkoztam ezeken de egyre
inkább azt vettem észre hogy magádnak a
tehát a a pszichológia az egy izgalmas
terület és ha valaki pszichológushoz
megy
nem nem beteg feltétlenül akár lehet
beteg is de lehet hog az azt a
betegséget nem úgy kell felfogni mint
egy tüdőgyulladást hanem valahogy úgy
gondolkozok úgy gondolok erre hogy egy
komplexitási problémája van hogy annyi
minden történik vele hogy szüksége van
arra hogy valaki meghallgassa egy külső
személy